[GUITAR MUSIC]
Hello, and welcome to another
Google Maps Developer
Relations screencast. My
name is Andres Ferrate.
And today I'll be talking about
our new Events feature
in the Google Places API.
That's right.
We've added a new Events feature
to our Places API.
OK, so what's up with this
new Events feature?
Well, with this new Events
feature, your users can add,
delete, find, and check-In to
events and places using the
Places API service.
Say for example, a donut shop.
The Events feature is accessed
via HTTP, using POST request.
And so here's an example
of a request for
Google's office in Sydney.
I'm going to submit
a new event.
That's right.
I'm going to add a happy hour
for Thursday afternoon, here
in the Sydney office.
Now the idea here is that you
can use this feature to
provide your users with
information about events that
are currently happening.
This could be one of the
millions of locations that we
currently have available
in the Places API.
And once they find an event,
users can check-in at a
specific place or they can
check-in to a specific event.
OK, so how do you get started?
Well, simply follow the
instructions in our reference
documentation at this URL.
And by the way, this is found
at our new home at
developers.google.com.
So yeah, check it out and let
us know what you think.
[GUITAR MUSIC]